I had a [__] audition for a ninja
recently it was a for a commercial no
line and I remember Lawrence horror who
was a Korean agent that I had Laura yeah
I love Lawrence Lawrence hey you got to
go get a ninja outfit you gotta go and I
go I go I know but the thing is is that
can't they Envision me in a ninja I'm
gonna go do I don't know where to go
I don't know right Party City I didn't
oh no no thank you next time I have but
now so I showed up and everyone was
wearing one and I just I was wearing
whatever I wear it was our one chance to
work all year you're gonna go you know
to the mat to do it right no I didn't I
didn't wear one a ninja did you get the
job no I remember hearing them going why
didn't you wear the thing and I went all
right all right and I laughed and I
remember going I refuse that was my line
I go there's no I can't yeah there's
another one where we just want you to
scream is this the Godzilla one yeah
yeah
King Kong right I go I scream there's no
line
no just run in a circle and scream
so I was in a room going
to be in a circle you know I mean it's
like the worst situations you know what
I mean and that's that was my audition
for the year yeah no I get it totally
get it I went to an audition once for a
commercial where uh it called for a
bunch of aliens like people from another
planet it's not not people from beings
for entities from another planet and
everyone in the audition waiting room
was Asian laughs
not not an exaggeration everyone wow
even though the commercial in the
commercial everyone was covered with
makeup so that you could not tell the
right race wow everyone was [__]
Asian I'll never forget that did you go
in uh
I don't remember I don't remember
whether I went into that audition or not
because I can't see you I can't see you
going on no see that's the thing like
yeah we've all had those lines that
we've had to draw and say like I am not
doing this all right yeah you know and
and it's good for all of us to know
because as we get older now it's not so
conflicting like when you're when you're
younger and you're trying to make it
you're like well what if this is my big
break you know like what if I say no and
my agent yells at me for not going to an
audition
all these things swirl in your head yeah
now it's so I I say no
to 95 of it I really do now now and it's
like it feels like so good because it I
feel like a human being I feel like
somebody like you know I feel like an
artist I feel like somebody that's like
a credible
performer right that I can look at a
project and go yeah it's not for me you
know I mean whereas 20 years ago I would
have sucked somebody's dick just to even
get in the room right it's so so let me
ask you something do you know because I
feel it do you feel the change I feel
the change in the last
10 years in Hollywood right in terms of
they're far more open and I feel more
you know I mean a part of it yeah 100
and good and you are a part of that the
fact that YouTube came around and
podcasts came around put more power in
the hands of creators and so there
weren't Gatekeepers you know the way
that there were you know 20 years ago
and I think there can be an over
correction when it comes to that because
there's always you know the people who
cry wolf and things like that it turns
into like The Crucible you know but uh
you know yeah yeah yeah but yeah the
point is that like there is a
like-mindedness that is taking over more
of the population now so we can say
names and we can prosecute and we can
write articles about them yeah I do feel
that man and I'm so glad I'm so glad
that I was around enough old enough and
also kind of still relevant enough to
like at least get some of it you know
what I mean because if it would happen
30 years from now you know I mean then
I've been [__] right so I was able to
get some some of it you know I mean and
it feels I just feel so great I feel
grateful about it mainly you know I mean
I really do I love that I mean you I'm
sure you're you do too right that a
feeling of like finally you know what I
mean yeah no 100 like when you see like
even when I saw I remember Joy Luck Club
when I saw that movie I was bawling in
the theater not just like tearing up
like ugly crying because I'd never seen
Asian Americans they weren't even men
all the men were [__] in that movie
but you know yeah yeah just to see even
you know all of us presented up there it
was uh Monumental and then crazy Rich
Asians the same way you know and seeing
your hearing seeing your podcast the
same way all of these things are
Groundswell yeah it's interesting
because you know I'm now you know
reoccurring on a bunch of shows and this
and that and I feel like you know when I
show up before this is something that
happened I don't know what happened but
20 years ago I would show up on a set
and I wouldn't talk to the producers
too scared didn't talk to the director
you know what I mean and I don't know if
it's the culture that changed or if I
changed but now when I'm on a show I I
am so comfortable with having developing
friendships with the producers and the
directors and we have dinner and this
and that before I was so petrified of it
all right it's both yeah I totally agree
you think so I think it's also not
outside of you just you know your own
personal growth I think the culture
changing also changed you right it sort
of made you less you know apprehensive
well no they're asking me now how I feel
about it
so I'll be on set now and a director our
produce will go so how do you feel about
this line or or this you know the the
direction that's you know characters
going whereas before I wouldn't have an
option do it like this
and then you're just like you know I
mean like freaking the [__] out you know
I mean because you know instinctually
you have ideas and things like what
about this what about that but you would
never [__] say it because you're just
you don't have the power yeah take
racing culture out of it it's about
power right any young actor who's on set
for the first time is not going to be
like I got a problem with this line
right here yeah you know yeah yeah
you're just happy to be there and you're
just gonna do whatever they say so that
you stay there yeah yeah so there's
something to be said for Success right
and experience